we have a voicemail number which is two
one nine to david p the egg man by and
large like our analysis of political
correctness and social justice warriors
but he keeps going back to one
particular term that he really wants to
be able to say without social
repercussions let's listen to the egg
man Dave I'm so thin-skinned I'm more
thin skins and Donald Trump and now
you're under my skin I agree with you on
all that politically correct stuff agree
with you are not using bad words
offensive works step the word [ __ ]
gosh dang it did to be [ __ ] is it is
it to be not fully developed in growth
mental growth for any kind of growth if
a medical term I can't [ __ ] people
but you're not [ __ ] every day yeah
okay so uh the eggman there a little bit
hard to hear towards the end here's the
problem yes uh mental retardation is a
medical term the problem is its use not
medically that's exactly why it's
offensive eggman which is its use not to
describe people that have a particular
uh medical condition which is mental
retardation but it is used as an insult
and in that way it is offensive to
people who have these of of mental
handicaps and that's exactly the point
it is used to make fun of people not as
a description of a medical condition
that's why it's offensive yeah and the
connotations of words will change over
time so maybe this wasn't considered as
offensive decades ago but now it is and
we should have that in mind the Eggman
is obsessed with this I think it's
probably a dozen times that in different
context he's gotten in touch and
explained how he really wants to be able
to use that word without above being
criticized or it being seen as somehow
insensitive on the bonus show today
Tyson Foods has launched a major uh
venture capital firm to invest in
alternatives to meet what does this tell
us about the future of the meat industry
also big developments in reproductive
health where infertile women have been
offered new hope after scientists found
a common cancer drug triggers the
development of new eggs which is
something that was previously thought to
be completely impossible and
what's the latest uh correct water
bottle or container that should be used
every time there's a new one there's
emails and people tweet to me saying oh
you shouldn't use this because it
leaches plastic and that one gives a
metallic taste and this one has some bad
chemical in it do we even have an
understanding right now of what the
right water container is that should be
used we will talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
remember that you can use coupon code I
voted 17 to get a big league discount
off of membership at david pakman.com
slash membership